[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und wir
kommen zu den nachrichten 20 minuten
natürlich auch mit sport und zwar mit
norbert lehmann talmud meiner familie
unsere großen themen heute
der kanzler bleibt dabei die ukraine
erhält keine direkten lieferungen
schwerer waffen aus deutschland
aber geld und waffen zu kaufen
putin will ihn zwickt erzwingen die
lange angekündigte offensive hat
begonnen das ziel die eroberung der ost
ukraine
und heißt null wird auch 0
menschlichkeit im kampf gegen omikron
sperrt china in shanghai zehntausende
infizierte in quarantäne lager wie
dieses
es war ein von vielen seit langem
verlangte auftritt vor gut einer halben
stunde ist kannst das holz für die
presse getreten und hat sich zur
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
geäußert nach einem telefonat mit
us-präsident beiden olaf scholz ist
nicht nur aus der union sondern auch aus
den parteien der ampel koalition
vorgeworfen worden zu zögerlich zu sein
patricia wiedemeier berichtet
vor einer knappen stunde gegen olaf
scholz dann doch vor die presse der
druck war wohl zu groß doch es gab keine
ganz klaren aussagen zum thema schwere
geräte nur so viel die ukraine werde
weiter geld bekommen für den kauf von
rüstungsgütern und entscheidend sei dass
zügig geliefert wird zusätzlich sind wir
bereit unsere nato partner die noch über
waffensysteme verfügen die aus der
russischen produktion stammen in der
ukraine selbst genutzt werden und sofort
einsetzbar sind zu unterstützen das ist
etwas was wir mit vielen anderen
zusammen so machen die rufe nach
schwerem gerät für die ukraine sie
wurden in den letzten tagen immer lauter
der bundeskanzler handele zu langsam tue
zu wenig so der vorwurf selbst die
zugesagte aufstockung der finanziellen
hilfen um eine milliarde der opposition
nicht genug
wir halten es für erforderlich dass
schwere waffen geliefert werden das ist
auch die meinung vieler in der koalition
nur der kanzler äußert sich nicht und
ist auch nicht zu einer entscheidung in
der lage der bundeskanzler die spd tage
lang unter druck sie verteidigten sich
bisher damit dass man tschechien
genehmigt habe panzer aus nva beständen
an die ukraine zu geben die bundeswehr
verfügt über keine weiterhin frei
verfügbaren waffen abgegeben werden
können deswegen muss jetzt die
industrien müssen wie gesagt auch
mögliche andere lieferungen möglich
gemacht werden die koalitionspartner
grüne und fdp sähen das anders bleiben
bei ihrer forderung nach schweren waffen
meine forderung ist erstmal und mein
wunsch dass der bundeskanzler sich jetzt
mal dafür ausspricht dass wir
grundsätzlich schwere waffen liefern
artillerie möglicherweise panzer die
zeit drängt der krieg wartet nicht bis
wir uns sortiert haben die
unionsparteien drohen nun damit den
bundestag darüber abstimmen zu lassen
der cdu-vorsitzende märz dazu heute auf
twitter der offen ausgetragene streit
der koalition schadet dem ansehen
unseres landes in der ganzen welt aber
es gibt eine mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag auch für schwere waffen an die
ukraine jenseits von spd fdp und
linkspartei
geld oder die lieferung schwerer waffen
oder beides der kanzler wird sich dieser
diskussion weiter dellen müssen
ja den auftritt des kanzlers tochter
käufe und verfolgt das unserem
hauptstadtstudio theo scholz stand ja
sehr unter druck wie bewerten sie denn
dann sein auftritt heute
da war eben ein bundeskanzler unter
druck zu erleben ein bundeskanzler der
sich und seine ukraine haltung zu
erklären versucht hat die kurze
pressekonferenz hatte durchaus auch
etwas von selbstverteidigung man habe
doch seit beginn schon waffen geliefert
aber eben nur solche waffen die zügig
liefer und einsetzbar gewesen sein dabei
sei man in den eigenen beständen rasch
an grenzen gestoßen eine position die ja
auch immer wieder kritisiert wird dass
das so sei man werde so sagte scholz
aber bei den osteuropäischen partner und
die noch waffen aus russischen beständen
hätten also solche die in der ukraine
schnell eingesetzt werden könnten auch
ohne schulung die werde man im
nachhinein beim nato partner dann durch
westliche waffen ersetzen da stand
spürbar in regierungschef der sich
erklären musste der auch aus den reihen
der eigenen ampel koalition massiv unter
beschuss geraten ist dort sogar ja
öffentlich als zauderer und zögerer
bezeichnet wird und auch deshalb hat
scholz wohlleben mehrfach die enge
abstimmung mit den verbündeten betont es
solle keine deutschen alleingänge geben
aktuell landet ein großteil der kritik
aber im berliner kanzleramt
einschätzung von theo koll vielen dank
herr letzte nacht hat sie begonnen die
lang erwartete großoffensive von putins
armee und der pro russischen verbände
eine neue phase des krieges wie auch
kanzler stolz meinte schauen wir auf die
lage im kampfgebiet
die frontlinien jeder russischen
offensive im osten zieht sich über
hunderte kilometer vom nordosten bis
südosten hier stoßen wir angreifer laut
ukrainischen angaben auf breiter linie
vor erklärtes ziel die region donetsk
und lohans komplett unter russische
kontrolle bringen schweren beschuss gab
es an vielen stellen besonders leidet
darunter die zivilbevölkerung christoph
testerei berichtet
ein sterbehospiz in der region donetsk
eigentlich wollten diese menschen in
würde ihr leben zu ende führen doch wer
noch die kraft hat muss jetzt den nimbus
zur evakuierung zurückbleiben die ans
bett gefesselten zu ihnen wird der krieg
kommen daran hat ihr präsident keinen
zweifel mehr
wir können jetzt sagen dass die
russischen kräfte nach langer
vorbereitung den kampf um das donbass
gestartet haben diese offensive wird
einen sehr großen teil ihrer armee
binden
bilder auf twitter zeigen russische
panzer angeblich auf dem weg zur
frontlinie 11 bataillone zusätzlich habe
russland mobilisiert glauben die usa das
wäre grob geschätzt war bis zu 10.000
soldaten mehr aber längst keine garantie
auf einen sieg glauben beobachter die
geringe moral der truppen die probleme
in der koordination die probleme in der
logistik die kann man nicht so schnell
überwinden deshalb können wir davon
ausgehen dass es bodengewinne geben wird
aber ob substanziell wirklich groß an
sich wird durchsetzen können ist zu
bezweifeln vom donders aus alles
kontrollieren bis runter zum strategisch
so wichtigen mariupol am asowschen meer
das ist wohl russisches minimalziel
dafür müssen die einwohner der quasi
schon zertrümmerten stadt weiter leiden
und sterben doch die im stahlwerk
eingeschlossenen letzten kämpfer ergeben
sich trotz ultimatum nicht 3000 mann
etwa sind das dazu kommen 1000
zivilisten die belagerer drohen ihnen
noch heute werde gestürmt ein ermüdung
streak der sich hier und im ganzen land
quälend hinzieht die schuld daran gibt
moskau anderen die westlichen staaten
versuchen alles um unsere militär
operation möglichst in die länge zu
ziehen das zeigen die gelieferten waffen
damit provozieren die usa und ihre
verbündeten das regime in kiew bis zum
letzten ukraine weiter kämpfen zu lassen
kiew seinerseits veröffentlichte bilder
von hochmotivierten soldaten die im
donbass auf die angreifer warten
beobachter sagen nicht nur um
verteidigung müsse es der ukrainischen
seite hierbei gehen auch darum möglichst
viel russisch kontrollierte gebiet im
osten zurück zu erobern das ist wichtig
weil das ende des krieges wurde an die
waffenstillstandslinie verläuft darüber
entscheiden wird wie die ukraine in
zukunft fortbestehen wird in welchen
grenzen sie bestehen wird zwei seiten zu
fast allem entschlossen ein grausamer
krieg könnte in den nächsten tagen noch
grausamer werden
und für uns vor ort in der ukraine ist
dominik lässt meister dominik die
ukrainische armee heck jetzt seit über
50 tagen den angriffen stand jetzt diese
grossoffensive wird die ukrainische
armee weiter gegen halten können
präsident selensky hat heute gesagt die
grüne wird kämpfen sie wird sich
verteidigen und wenn man sich die
schlacht um kiew ansieht dort hatte die
ukraine erfolg und die russischen
truppen mussten sich zurückziehen das
lag vor allem an der hohen kampfes moral
der ukraine sie haben ihr land
verteidigt und das hat hier in kiew
zumindest zum erfolg geführt bei dieser
offensiven dombach muss man sehen dass
die strategische lage etwas anders ist
man hat es ihrem beitrag schon gesehen
eine sehr lange frontlinie und jetzt ein
massiver angriff wir hören auch von
heftigen gefechten von einsätzen der
luftwaffe der artillerie und das wird
sich jetzt die nächsten tage zeigen ob
die russischen truppen vorstöße
realisieren können sich halten können
und ob die ukraine ihr land verteidigen
können das werden jetzt spannende tage
werden hier in der ukraine
was diesen krieg angeht und was diese
zweite offensive wie es hier heißt wir
jetzt auch zeigen wird damals meister
aus kiew dankeschön und
ein zdf spezial zum krieg in der ukraine
können sie gleich nach dieser heute
sendung sehen wegen des ukraine krieges
senkt der internationale währungsfonds
seine prognosen für die weltwirtschaft
für dieses jahr um 0,8 punkte auf nur
noch 3,6 prozent für den gesamten euro
raum rechnet der iwf jetzt mit
geringeren wachstumsraten für russland
und die ukraine sogar mit schweren
rezessionen und die ohnehin schon hohe
inflation dürfte der krieg weiter
anheizen
mit spannung und bei vielen auch mit
anspannung wird darauf gelegt wer am
sonntag nächster präsident oder nächste
präsidentin frankreichs wird in der
stichwahl amtsinhaber emanuel marco und
die rechtsextreme marien im falle einer
wiederwahl markus hat premierminister
kast ex bereits eine regierungsumbildung
angekündigt macau liegt in umfragen
vorne aber nur knapp thomas walde über
das enge rennen
nach ostern beginnt der endspurt in der
arbeiterstadt lille versuchen anhänger
des präsidenten vor allem linke wähler
zu gewinnen eine schwere aufgabe
die menschen in den sozial schwachen
vierteln wurden vergessen makros der
präsident der reichen er hat die
kaufkraft aller auch der armen um fünf
prozent erhöht und es gab einen
inflationsausgleich für alle
viele linke tun sich schwer sich
zwischen makro le pen und einer
enthaltung zu entscheiden das ist schwer
pest oder cholera zu wählen
die kandidatin der extremen rechten
arbeitet derweil vor allem an ihrem
image sie macht chelseas herz babys will
menschlich und weniger radikal
erscheinen
ich bin zuversichtlich das volk
unterstützt mich
die makro will seiner konkurrentin die
zur schau gestellte harmlosigkeit nicht
durchgehen lassen heute griff er sie
scharf an
sie hat ihre fassade ein wenig geändert
um akzeptabler zu wirken aber sie
vertritt die alten ideen sie will aus
dem euro ohne es zu sagen das ist die
extreme rechte
emanuel marco hat zuletzt in den
umfragen ein wenig zugelegt weil der
abstand aber immer noch recht knapp ist
warnen nun zahlreiche künstler sportler
und gewerkschafter vor marine le pen und
ihrer europafeindlichen haltung viel
wird abhängen von der tv debatte morgen
abend denn es wird das einzige direkte
aufeinandertreffen der beiden
konkurrenten
in den usa müssten die menschen den
flugzeugen zügen und bussen vorerst
keine masken mehr tragen eine
bundesrichterin in florida erklärte die
korona maßnahme für rechtswidrig mit der
verfügung habe die nationale
gesundheitsbehörde ihre befugnisse
überschritten so die begründung das
weiße haus nannte die entscheidung
enttäuschend und rief dazu auf weiter
maske zu tragen gegen beschluss kann das
justizministerium berufung einlegen
einen ganz anderen weg in der pandemie
geht china die regierung verfolgt eine
null kowitz strategie aber omikron
breitet sich immer weiter aus in
shanghai ist die zahl der toten auf zehn
gestiegen
seit einem märz schon müssen hier rund
26 millionen menschen zu hause bleiben
trotzdem gibt es rund 20.000 neue fälle
pro tag die behörden reagieren rigoros
wie ulf röller berichtet
das chinesische fernsehen zeigt gerne
drohnen flüge von shanghai von oben soll
alles geordnet wirken die propaganda
verbreitet bilder von helfern die
lebensmittel verteilen die quarantäne
unterkünfte wirken wie hotels die null
kowitz strategie funktioniere so die
botschaft wir haben alle zimmer und
fenster mit schlössern ausgestattet das
wasser von keimen befreit und den boden
gereinigt
doch die wut der shanghaier wächst im
chinesischen netz schockieren aufnahmen
von polizisten die bürger festnehmen die
behörden zwingen sie ihre wohnungen zu
verlassen
denn daraus soll eine quarantäne
unterkunft entstehen chinas führung
fürchtet im corona chaos zu versinken
wenn
sie so weitermachen gibt es für china
keine hoffnung mehr sagt der polizist zu
der festgenommenen frau wir werden bald
krieg mit amerika haben das wissen sie
doch nur die kommunistische partei kann
uns retten
die zustände in den provisorischen
quarantäne unterkünften sind oft
verheerend dreckige toiletten
die menschen sind ein gefecht jeder der
positiv getestet wird muss in eine
quarantäne unterkunft egal ob er
symptome hat oder nicht bye bye ist in
der größten shanghais 50.000 betten es
gibt keine ausreichende medizinische
versorgung erklärt sie uns
es gibt keine warmen duschen das licht
ist die ganze nacht an
shanghai im ausnahmezustand die
propaganda zeigt tanzende bürger in der
quarantäne
im fall neuer card gibt es eine neue
entwicklung und es geht um den
flüchtigen ex vorstand jan marschalek
der schon länger in russland vermutet
wird die münchner staatsanwaltschaft hat
sich ein bericht zufolge an die
russische regierung gewandt und
beantragt marschalek festzunehmen und
auszuliefern
er ist eine schlüsselfigur im wirecard
skandal der zusammenbruch des
finanzdienstleisters gilt als grösster
betrugsfall der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte und wir blicken
nach südafrika dort hat präsident
drummer fossa nach den verheerenden
überschwemmungen der vergangenen tage
landesweit den katastrophenzustand
ausgerufen
bislang wurden mindestens 4 148 menschen
tot aus trümmern und schlamm geborgen
das leben von tausenden dass nach den
worten des präsidenten weiter gefährdet
in der provinz kwazulu natal wird weiter
nach vermissten gesucht der wichtige
hafen von durban bleibt bis auf weiteres
geschlossen aus südafrika berichtet
sandra theis
rettungskräfte suchen nach überlebenden
doch inzwischen bergen sie fast nur noch
leichen es sind gefährliche einsätze vor
zwei tagen starben in einer ähnlichen
situation eine taucherin und ihr suche
und sie waren in einem fluss in
schwierigkeiten geraten insgesamt kamen
hunderte menschen ums leben 48 gelten
aktuell als vermisst wir suchen nach
unserer nachbarin sie wurde vom fluss
davon gerissen wir sind uns dessen
sicher weil wir den körper ihres sohnes
schon gefunden haben sie aber noch nicht
die strom und trinkwasserversorgung sind
teilweise unterbrochen viele füllen an
beschädigten leitungen eimer und
kanister andere sind auf tanklaster
angewiesen doch in manche gebiete
konnten die helfer bislang noch nicht
einmal vordringen für die einsatzkräfte
gelten klare prioritäten
fürs als erstes kümmern wir uns um die
sofortige humanitäre hilfe um
sicherzustellen dass alle betroffenen in
sicherheit sind und eine basisversorgung
haben
als zweites konzentrieren wir uns auf
stabilisierung und wiederherstellung und
darum jene menschen unterzubringen die
ihr zuhause verloren haben
und das sind viele nach jetzigem stand
sind rund 40.000 menschen durch
erdrutsche und überschwemmungen
obdachlos geworden
dramatischen folgen der flutkatastrophe
in südafrika und jetzt jetzt kommen wir
zum sport und fun mit dem dfb-pokal mit
den frauen hat da steht er jetzt das
finale die wolfsburgerinnen die hatten
sich am sonntag gegen die bayern
durchgesetzt gestern gewann die erste
ffc turbine potsdam sein halbfinalspiel
in leverkusen eine spannende begegnung
bei der alle tore durch elfmeter fielen
das elfmeter tore pures glück erzeugen
können wissen die favorisierten
potsdamerinnen spätestens seit gestern
zunächst aber dürfen nach einem foul die
leverkusenerinnen vom punkt schießen
lackovic mit dem 10 die bayer fans
träumen bis zur 83 minute von finale
dann aber verursacht jessica wich einen
hand elfmeter für potsdam
isabel kerschowski
überwindet anna klingt gerade so eins zu
eins verlängerung in der kann keiner der
beiden trainer jubeln das
elfmeterschiessen muss also entscheiden
und in dem hat leverkusen pech nach
latte 7 trifft zum 4 2 im
elfmeterschießen
potsdam im finale gegen wolfsburg
und bei den männern gibt es heute und
morgen die beiden dfb pokal halbfinals
am abend trifft der hsv auf freiburg der
zweitligist aus hamburg kaum noch mit
chancen auf den bundesliga-aufstieg
dafür aber lockt das pokalfinale am 21
mai in berlin vor 35 jahren reckte
kapitän manni kaltz zum letzten mal für
den hsv den pokal in die höhe und das
ist für die hamburger schon viel zu
lange her im bock auf dieses spiel ist
eine eine tolle plattform wir haben
ausverkauftes haus der hsv muss heute
gewinnen denn nur ein erfolg könnte den
schmerz über den erneuten nichtaufstieg
mildern die freiburger hingegen
schnuppern auf platz 5 weiter an den
champions-league-plätzen und trainer
christian streich ist ein echter pokal
profi mit den freiburger a junioren hat
er die trophäe schließlich schon dreimal
gewonnen
[Applaus]
fußball-nationalspieler nico
schlotterbeck steht laut medienberichten
vor dem wechsel vom sc freiburg zum bvb
der 22 jährige nationalspieler hat den
dortmund an demnach eine zusage für
seinen transfer im sommer gegeben beide
vereine müssen sich jetzt noch über die
ablösesumme einigen schauen wir mal dass
der belastung das wasser im sport danken
auch morgen weht der wind meist aus
nordost was das für unser wetter
bedeutet das erfahren sie gleich von
katja hall war das heute journal können
sie um 22.15 sehen mit bettina schausten
und jetzt geht's erst mal weiter mit
einem zdf spezial zum krieg in der
ukraine machen sie es gut auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute zogen die wolken zur
abwechslung mal aus boston heran und
wenn sie ganz genau hinschauen dann
sehen sie nicht nur in blau regenfälle
sondern auch in violett oder rosa etwas
schneeregen oder schnee der fiel im
berchtesgadener land oder auch in den
alpen diese dichteren wolken hier im
osten die beschäftigen uns auch noch in
der nacht im westen ist es dagegen klar
und an den alpen kann es etwas regnen
die temperaturen sinken auf plus drei
grad auf rügen und -3 grad in der
oberpfalz milder bleibt ist in der
uckermark und ganz im westen bei 6 bis 4
grad das west-ost-gefälle bei den
temperaturen beschäftigt uns auch noch
morgen im osten bleibt es bei zehn bis
maximal 15 grad eher kühl im westen wird
es bei 14 bis 19 grad etwas milder und
ähnliche heute strahlt auch morgen in
der westhälfte die sonne im osten gibt
es dichtere wolken besonders im
nordosten und hier und da kann es auch
mal ein bisschen regnen in den nächsten
tagen ändert sich am wetter wenig es
bleibt bei dem leichten bis mäßigen
nordostwind über den norden ziehen
dichtere wolken im süden gibt es
sonnenschein aber erst am samstag kann
es dann im südwesten mal für ein kleines
gewitter reichen bei 10 bis 21 grad
guten abend